well we're gonna turn up the volume it's
been a quiet conference so far but I
figure when we brought Elan musk in here
I had a chance to meet with Elan know
and actually Scott Schlegel and I were
out in San Jose about a month ago and
this is a man who really knows how to
push the envelope and change American
manufacturing I kept staring at this
Carl morning I keep worrying about
someone left the lights on because
you're a normal car you'd have to turn
the lights off pretty fast before you
run down the battery but Elon told me
that he could probably last a good month
before so we had a little controversy
what to bring in the room we were
thinking about a rocket we thought about
a number of other things that was hard
to get in so this was the smallest
product we could kind of squeeze into
the showroom to get started so let me
ask when you know I met about a month
ago and you just came back from China
you said to me about half your
productions gonna be exporting so could
you talk a little about that and how
much is going to China and what what
that looks like
sure so I actually just came back from
China yesterday fact I was there all
week until yesterday evening and I the
thing that really surprised me was how
positive the reception was for Tesla I
going in there I was I would win there
was some trepidation thinking that
they'd be concerned about an American
car company exporting cars to China and
and that maybe there would be somewhere
between indifferent to slightly hostile
but but but actually I didn't
encountered that at all in fact they
were incredibly friendly and supportive
including modifying some of their
programs which offer electric vehicle
incentives to include
import electric cars and they actually
made that and now that announcement for
example Shanghai has the license plate
fee that's that's paid normally for a
gasoline car and on the day that I
arrived there they changed it to include
imported electric
vehicles as being having no license
plate fee and so it was just really
really amazed and and and at the
positive reception and among the public
Tesla is is viewed super positively it
was like when I held these customer
events to hand over cars it was like a
like a pop concert I mean it was just
crazy but by far the most positive
reception of any place I've been
so we handed over the first cars at
first has the vehicles introduction
vehicles in China this week - very
excited customers and and yeah we expect
probably will end up exporting half or
maybe a little more than half of the
cars we manufacture in California to
overseas and all that number probably
half will go to China alone so so many
companies might include it look at
exporting after you've saturated the US
market you're clearly not doing that so
maybe you could talk about that you're
early on the journal is gonna be
exporting close to half your production
could you talk to us about that yeah I
think I think it makes sense to to not
sort of saturate one market before
moving to another I mean there's
certainly true that we started
deliveries in the US well in advance of
deliveries to China in fact almost two
years in advance so so we started off
with with the liveries essentially mid
2012 in the US and then a little over a
year later started deliveries in Europe
and then about eight months after that
we start deliveries in China and I will
and later this year we'll be starting
right-hand-drive deliveries for the UK
Japan Australia and and probably South
Africa since I'm originally from South
Africa got a lot of complaints about why
the hell look the car's not there but
I was like we're getting there some
people compared the Tesla to a and like
it's somewhat like an iPhone on wheels
is that is that the right analogy to
make I have two of them right yeah but
yeah I mean just basically get some
wheels glued on your iPhone and you're
good to go I mean it's pretty much the
same thing so it there are certainly
some analogies that in that direction
that makes sense I'm gonna do sometimes
in fact myself referred to it as a
computer on wheels it's I mean it's more
than an electric car it's actually I
think you call that that's really
designed to take advantage of 21st
century technology so it's got a 17 inch
touchscreen display it's always
connected to the Internet via a cell
modem or via Wi-Fi you can ask for any
song any time just by literally asking
for it so if you hold down the voice
button and say play ring a fire by
Johnny Cash it'll play it you say play
the cheese shop sketch by Monty Python
anything you like the most obscure thing
the car will actually play it on demand
and it just works you don't have to do
anything so and you can you can adjust
the caused parameters like the ride
height of the vehicle you can do not
adjust dynamically from the center
screen and it this soon will be
releasing real-time traffic so the cause
will collaborate as a network fleet to
optimize the route to your destination
that's going to be pretty exciting and
we're adding a lot much more
functionality to the car
even after you bought the car it keeps
getting better because a bit of added
software functionality that we download
to it at no charge and what makes this
what makes it to us a really good
platform to manufacture these and export
these from the US well to me it is a
good plug yes they certainly have been
accused of doing of that being foolish
but
I think the you know I'm someone who
believes in manufacturing I like
manufacturing I like making things and I
think for some reason that got out of
out of fashion
I don't sure why but I think if you if
you if you think of manufacturing not as
some boring process of making Roach
copies but rather that the manufacturing
system that creates the car is itself a
very complex machine and just as
innovation applies to the design of the
engineering of the car you can you can
apply and should apply innovation to the
machine that makes the machine and you
can come up with some really cool new
ways to manufacture a vehicle and I also
believe in having a tight feedback loop
between engineering and production and
so if if production is far away from
engineering you lose that feedback loop
and so someone who designed the car in a
particular way doesn't realize that it's
very difficult to manufacture the
particular way that's designed but if if
the factory floor is a 50 feet away from
their desk then they can go out and they
can just see it and it's obvious and
they can have a dialogue with the people
on the floor and likewise a lot of
people in the manufacturing team have
great ideas about how to improve the car
but if they're far away they can't
communicate that to the engineers who
designed it so I think that it's an it's
a something that's often neglected but
having that strong bi-directional
feedback loop between engineering and
production is really helpful for making
car better and finding efficiencies and
lowering the cost where do you think the
strongest markets going to be for your
car and also where the Rick West
competition might come from
I'm sure so I think we're all right now
the United States is is our strongest
market and I in a long term we might
actually sell more cars in China than in
the u.s. just because the Chinese market
is is so huge in fact last year China
became the world's largest car market
and in fact it's disproportionately so
for premium sedans and they have
somewhat of a bimodal distribution with
a very high demand for premium cost and
then a very very high demand for economy
cars and it was sort of a bit of a dip
in the middle and so for example for
Mercedes s classes more than half of all
Mercedes s classes last year were sold
in China worldwide so it was like two or
three times what they sold in the US so
given that that's the basis for things
then I would expect just on sheer
numbers China is probably larger than
the US market over time but that may
take a few years to arise and what's the
we talked a little bit and people may be
filled this room may be interested what
with this car sell for here this one
here so that the the Tesla car starts at
about seventy thousand dollars before
incentives right
and with incentives and in California
it's about sixty thousand dollars okay I
should say so one thing that's important
to consider though is that the the cost
of electricity is much less than the
cost of gasoline and you also don't have
to do smog checks or oil changes or a
lot of the things that you'd ordinarily
have to spend on maintenance for a
gasoline car so the operating costs are
much lower and the Tesla supercharger
network is free so you can go you have
free long distance travel anywhere in
the country so when you when you net
that out it's somewhere in the order of
twelve to fifteen thousand dollars of
value so it's actually like maybe
compare apples to apples to a gasoline
car it's maybe like a gasoline car in
the mid to high 50s
huh and what's the impediment towards I
know you've talked about a car in the
thirty thirty five thousand dollar range
is that about cost of batteries what's
the what's the technological
breakthrough we've got to get through as
a country absolutely so the goal of
Tesla from the beginning has been to
create an affordable and compelling
mass-market electric vehicle it but in
order to get there it requires at least
three major iterations of technology and
it requires very large-scale production
so you gotta have the economies of scale
and you've got to have design iteration
this is this has been true of any new
technology of any kind that's really
ever been introduced if you can sort of
say cell phones and how they started out
you know wall street wine you had this
giant brick the guy was walking down the
you know the beach on your list of
talking to but on the size of a shoebox
and and now we've got phone that's tiny
and it's the back of the power of a
supercomputer and you can buy one for
about a hundred bucks so that that's
gone through many design iterations with
electric cars we're trying to get to
mass market in just three major design
iterations which is I think about as
fast as you can do it and to get from
where we are right now to the $35,000
price point there are companies first of
all that car would be about 20% smaller
than the Model S so just the first
proximation that would drop the cost
about 20% for it to achieve the other
30% of cost savings we need to take
advantage of the design improvements and
the economies of scale I'm very
confident that we can achieve that
additional 30% improvement with both of
those in fact I'd say III am 99% sure
you know I wish Jim okay that's 99 is a
good number let me ask you we've done
more work with your other company
actually we made you be working with
down exports but mostly on SpaceX and
we've learned that about 60% of US
commercial satellites finance actually
by the expert input
and we there's been a great mustering of
interest we recently did a transaction
with SpaceX from Bulgaria sad what's
driving this whole the satellite
industry what's is I mean obviously it's
iPhones and streaming maybe you could
give us some more insight you mean what
would this whole satellite boom that is
actually also been a parsec story and
part of what we've been working on can
you give us some insight on the
satellite marketplace well I'd like what
place isn't isn't quite it mean the
excellent financing may be increasing in
recent years but the in terms of the
number of satellites it's a relatively
steady flow of commercial satellites
there's about roughly 40 large
commercial commercial satellites that
are launched every year and these are
satellites that are used for broadcast
communications in some cases weather
mapping putting in for Google Maps that
and this is a whole bunch of satellites
of all different types and yeah so if
it's pretty steady you know a bad year
might be thirty a good year might be 50
something like that and where it's
really important you know where
excellence really important is in
helping fund the fund those missions
actually it's a the money doesn't
doesn't go to SpaceX it's really to the
satellite otras satellite operator who
wants to operate a particular satellite
for a particular purpose and then they
will contract with a satellite maker and
no contract with a launch provider and
sometimes that SpaceX and then they will
try to get the lowest cost of funds to
to fund that and the excellent really
important in this equation because well
the French have this thing called Co
fast which
is very aggressive in providing low-cost
funding and if we didn't have the
American to Exim Bank the it were very
difficult for us to compete on the
international market because the French
tend to favor their domestic rocket
company and you all say well yes they'll
provide low-cost funding if you use the
ariane rocket and so it's really
important to have the u.s. in our corner
with the Exim Bank to counter the
actions of go-fast and what has changed
I mean I I was in prepared for today in
the 1980s there was almost zero
commercial satellites launched the
United States now I'm told around 10%
and growing what what change that this
has become is that all SpaceX or it's
mostly space mostly a sec yeah so
actually before the fall of the Soviet
Union the United States used to launch a
very high percentage of commercial
satellites in fact the US was the leader
in commercial satellite launch but with
full the Soviet Union the Russian rocket
industry was able to figure out how to
be capitalist really fast and and they
since of the USSR invested so much money
in rocket technology they actually had
really good rockets and and arguably the
best rocket technology in the world at
the time of the fullest third year
Soviet Union so they were able to
completely take the the commercial
launch market away from the United
States so in the United States went from
within the course of really just a few
years from being the leader in
commercial satellite launch to being
non-existent virtually and and then then
the French with the Ariane and it was a
little bit of help from Germany and
Italy put a ton of money into the Ariane
5 rocket also a good rocket
and local in the world rush launch
market then became essentially divided
between the Russians and the French the
Russians probably about having about
three-quarters of the business in the
French having about a quarter and that
continued on quite a while until a few
years ago when SpaceX started launching
the Falcon 9 and since since then we've
steadily increased the share of us u.s.
one missions and I think we're now now
about a quarter of all commercial
satellite missions are won by a US
company we'll really run by SpaceX and I
think that's we've got a decent shot if
we if we you know keep at it of
achieving a majority of the commercial
launch market winning over a majority
the commercial market and that's what
yeah but don't yeah don't count chickens
before they've hatched but it it's
looking increasingly positive that that
will probably you know will probably
restore the United States number one on
commercial launches in the world you
also do a lot of work for the u.s.
government in the Air Force in the
launcher could what what portion of that
is your business can you talk just it's
not really we're on the more commercial
side but Brian still fill it out well
actually uh as far as US government
launches go we have a very good
relationship with NASA NASA has been
fantastic to work with and really has
helped us a lot and in fact I'm not sure
we'd even be where we are today with
without the help of NASA so we're very
grateful to them NASA selected us as the
primary system for transferring cargo to
and from the space station and so in
fact our dragon spacecraft is the only
spacecraft capable of taking any
significant cargo down from the space
station so their variety of means of
getting to the space station but in
bringing experiments back which is
critical to leverage the value of the
space station our spacecraft is the only
one capable of doing that and I'd like
to also note that our we get paid half
as much permission as orbital sciences
so there's another provider and they
only take stuff up they take up less
than we do and they take nothing down
and they get paid twice as much per
mission as we do but that's okay I mean
I'm not for the US taxpayers no I I mean
I think maybe they should get fewer
missions in the future but but you know
I'm glad that we were able to you know
provide a service that's twice the value
for money that you know the competitor
does when I was out at SpaceX about a
year ago I noticed that you also
developing a recyclable rocket rocket
did actually come back to earth yeah it
would be the ultimate recyclable can you
yes about that well this is the
fundamental breakthrough that's needed
in space transport to fundamentally
transform it because I think what we've
done thus far at SpaceX is evolutionary
but not revolutionary you know we've
we've made a rocket that in an
expendable scenario is is it's better
than anything else out there I can in
that video but by maybe 20 and it's like
the next best rocket be like 20 to 30
percent worse in efficiency so but that
but that's definitely an evolutionary
thing it's not going to revolutionize
spaceflight to really have a
revolutionary impact we've got to
achieve at least an order of magnitude
improvement maybe a two order of
magnitude improvement and the only way
to achieve that is with full and rapid
reusability and that was a very
difficult thing to achieve in fact a lot
of people in the
and the earth space industry think it's
not possible and in fact most have given
up on it
but I think it is possible and we
recently achieved an important milestone
which was to get the blue stage of the
rocket to re-enter the atmosphere intact
deploy landing legs and and and achieve
a soft landing up in the ocean so we're
first doing this in the ocean to make
sure we can line accurately and then
hopefully later this year we will
transition to landing back on land at
Cape Canaveral and then we'll what came
to reef lie that that blue stage
probably next year if this year works
out and and that will really be a
massive change in in space transport to
give it sort of a sense of the potential
there the cost of the fuel and oxygen
and other sort of expandable liquids in
in the rocket they'll cost to
effectively fuel it up is only 0.3
percent of the cost of the mission so
it's the rocket costs sixty million
dollars only costs a couple hundred
thousand dollars to fill it up so the
potential is there with a high launch
rate if one can achieve full and rapid
reasonability to improve the cost of
space access by a factor of more than
100 well any advice what would you what
what could you what could we as citizens
do what can the US government do to make
this a better place to support business
make America even a better place to
start a business you came from South
Africa what else could we be doing to
improve that from your point of
and I think the United States is pretty
great
honestly definitely the best place in
the world to start a business and
particular involves technology you know
I think certainly we need to take a look
at our immigration laws you know if
there are really talented people you're
doing grad graduate courses in
engineering at our universities we
really don't want to send them home we
want to try to reopen you can to keep
them here because like if you for every
one person who's like a like an ace
engineer that they're probably like ten
jobs that will be paraded if that person
stays here it's a huge multiplier effect
and conversely if you're missing that
special ingredient it's very difficult
to create them I think also we probably
need to reform our tax laws because the
US corporate tax rate is really high
relative to say the EU and what this
causes companies to do like inter Apple
or Google or others basics as SpaceX is
a purely domestic company so okay we're
happy about yeah yeah so you know we we
don't have the ability to play you know
sort of some sort of tax shell game and
we wouldn't but right the but but it is
tricky like if you're head of a
multinational and you got all these
shareholders who are expecting you to
maximize profits and and you can play
this sort of like international tax
shell game and you and you're sort of
that there's a strong incentive to do so
because of the US tax rate being way out
of whack with almost any other country
what this causes covers like Apple and
Google to do is to invest a ton of money
in other countries right so this is a
big gift that we're giving to other
countries so instead of getting those
you know sort of ace ace engineers and
others to move to the US and create a
bunch of drugs here we're at
the funding them there to create jobs
there and it's quite a nice thing we're
doing but it's you know probably not in
the best overly generous very generous
very generous yeah let me ask you a
final question cuz we've gotta we're
gonna wrap up you have five sons so it's
hard to be a cool dad what are your kids
think is the coolest thing about dad I'm
mature I'm rocking to the cars but you
know they don't seem too excited about
these things because I grew up you know
I take them to the factory and it's like
you know is this exciting they're like
oh we're seeing up 20 times well you get
more excitement at one age really
yeah no I know maybe they were secretly
excited and there's still one later on
but you know to me but I you know to try
to get them excited about these things
and but they seem to be like more
excited about like if I play a video
game with them that seems to be like
they're the favorite thing but they're
only like the twins or tan and the
triplets are seven so they're young side
all right well thank you thank you for
joining us say let's give me round